Lauren Bushnell got the final rose and
this huge ring during Monday's bachelor
finale but she tells ET it wasn't
exactly easy watching Ben Higgins woo
other women on the show you know what
it's so confusing because here we are
you know weeks out of being engaged in
our relationships progressed even
farther than when we first got engaged
so it's hard sometimes for your mind to
separate the two you're like okay I know
this happened weeks ago but your
rewatching it you're like wait like
you're cheating on me or somebody it's
not fun to like watch your fiance
kissing other women and during Monday's
after the final rose there was one thing
that Ben said that had a few others
upset you know honestly for me like I
just want to like show her off a little
bit of backlash for that on Twitter some
some people thought it was sexist set
the record straight
I think we are are now a couple and
we're here to support each other and
when I said that you're never you know
everything's gonna be taken in correctly
at times I'm in it like she's a
beautiful person who I just can't wait
to share life with and show people that
I'm sharing life with her as she's
sharing life with me I think that's the
part I'm most excited for is just to be
a couple in public
runner up Jojo will continue looking for
love as the Bachelorette next season and
Lauren thinks she's the perfect choice I
mean I wasn't surprised when I heard
Jojo because she's fun and I mean she's
gonna have no problem finding it guys
are gonna be lined up you know out the
door